تقوم United Airlines بتطهير
كل شيء من تسجيل الوصول إلى طاولات التجارة
هنا في مركز Dulles الخاص بها ، ولكن من
وراء الكواليس يمكنك رؤية مقدار
خسائر شركات الطيران التجارية ، فقد رأينا 26
طائرة في المخزن فقط بعض أسطول United
الذي تم إيقافه بواسطة هذا
الوباء منذ مارس مع تزايد الطلب
علينا أن نكون مستعدين ، تعمل أطقم الصيانة براين كورز
على طائرات
يأملون فقط أن تطير مرة أخرى قريبًا
تقول إدارة أمن المواصلات إنها سجلت أخيرًا أيامًا
عندما مر أكثر من نصف مليون شخص
عبر الأمن ولكن هذا فقط
جزء بسيط من الصيف الماضي عندما كان أكثر من
مليوني ونصف المليون أمريكي
يسافرون كل يوم ، هل ستسافر بالطائرة الآن نعم
بالتأكيد سأطير الآن ، مدير المركز ،
عمر إدريس ، هو جزء من جهود يونايتد
العاجلة لجعل الناس يسافرون مرة أخرى ،
يجب على الركاب ارتداء أقنعة على
متن الطائرة  من الخلف إلى الأمام ويتم إعطاؤهم مناديل مبللة
لفحص الحمى عندما
يبدأون مناوبة ، وسيواصلون
العمل حتى سبتمبر بفضل
السلاسل المرتبطة بالصناعة ب  ailout
ولكن بعد ذلك ، تتوقع شركات الطيران بالفعل
الإجازات وتسريح العمال ، حيث يحتاج
مضيفو الطيران مثل سوزانا كار
إلى الصناعة لاستعادة هذا
الوقت المخيف للغاية عندما نسمع عن
تأثير شركة طيران أصبحت شركات
طيران أصغر تُبقي بعض المقاعد
فارغة للتباعد الاجتماعي دلتا على سبيل المثال
تبلغ طاقتها الاستيعابية 60٪ ،
لكن لا تزال شركات الطيران بحاجة إلى بيع
المقاعد المتاحة.يقول يونايتد إن هذه الرحلة
إلى شيكاغو كانت ممتلئة بنسبة 30٪ فقط ، وهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نرى فيها عملية التنظيف هذه
لأنفسنا ، يستغرق الأمر حوالي 10
دقائق لرش 787 بالكامل.
من المؤكد أن هذا يمثل تحديًا
، لكننا نتحرك جميعًا
لتحقيق بصيص أمل
يقول يونايتد إنها ستضيف رحلات في يوليو
وتستأنف أكثر من 140 مسارًا
تقوم دلتا بنفس الشيء جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية ولكنها متعطشة لتحقيق عائدات لشركات الطيران  بحاجة إلى تسلق أسرع للوصول إلى
الهواء السلس ، فهناك الكثير من القلق مع
عملائنا ، وهناك الكثير من القلق
مع
موظفنا فيما يتعلق بخدمات الطيران.  بشكل عام
ولكننا واثقون من أنه سيعود